make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and we are picking back up again
with the king in black this time we're
focusing on
venom but i do have a question for you
guys right now we're covering
uh miles morales spider-man here on
comics explain and we don't really have
a schedule for him right it's just kind
of
fitting him in wherever we really have
space on the channel it used to be
that we had like different days
dedicated to different things
so that people who wanted to see miles
morales comics could come in on a
certain day people who wanted to see
spider-man can come in on a certain day
things like that and i've thought about
returning to that as opposed to the kind
of hodgepodge uploading schedule that we
have at the moment so let me know if you
guys are interested in seeing that
return we're like we dedicate a single
day to miles morales like sunday would
be miles morales comics day and also a
lot of you guys have asked for agent
venom is that still something you guys
want to see right do you guys still want
to see a series on agent venom because
we can dedicate like saturday to agent
venom
or something along those lines right so
just let me know that's something you
guys are interested in seeing down in
the comments section
but uh but this basically picks up kind
of really between
like the last video that we did the main
king and black story and this
tie-in right here right this venom story
and it really picks up with spider-man
talking to
dylan the son of eddie brock in the
aftermath of dylan basically losing his
dad losing eddie brock and one of the
things that spider-man says here this is
one of the reasons why i feel like
donnie cates would have an amazing
spider-man run one of the things that
spider-man says here to dylan
is that he understands he knows what
it's like to lose right to feel so
desperately that you're right but to
fail all the same you know like he
understands
you know what it means what it feels
like to lose someone but he also
understands how hard life
can be after that right that you know it
almost seems like the world has it out
for you because you'll lose the people
who are the closest to you but the world
just keeps spinning
and the world hardly even notices you
lost that person in the first place that
for dylan it feels like the world is
crashing down right it feels like his
entire world has just come to a
screeching halt but the reality is
the world keeps going right there are
people who wake up in the morning and
they go through their morning routine
and they get in their car
and they deal with rush hour traffic
they get to work they do their job they
go home they watch their favorite tv
show or they spend time with their kids
all the while
totally oblivious to the fact that dylan
lost his dad and and the reality is that
people like me or you who have
experienced loss
in that way you know a close individual
to us and in my case my parents
uh we understand what that feels like
and that's why having you know kind of
reading spider-man or having you know
reading a point where spider-man has
this conversation with dylan is an
interesting thing because spider-man
kind of goes on he doesn't really make
it all
you know melancholy and sad instead he
kind of says for so many people who are
out there it's much easier to just lay
down and to just let all those hits let
the world hitting you just wash over
right because the the toughness and the
difficulty of the world
keeps going on and the world will keep
coming at you with hits and for some
people it's easy to just lay down and
just let it happen and just let them get
beat up but he says for people like
dylan you know and really spider-man
himself
they have the power to change it now i
would extrapolate that i would expand
that out and i would say
that applies to everybody that we know
that a lot of us know what it's like to
experience
loss to experience you know losing
something that's significant to us and
it puts us in a place where we feel like
the world comes crashing down
around us but i would say each and every
one of us has that inherent ability to
stand up
right just like rocky balboa said you
know sylvester sloan said in the rocky
balboa movie it's not about how hard you
can you can hit
it's about how hard you can get hit and
keep moving forward that's the message
that spider-man is giving to dylan here
that you've experienced a huge loss and
yes reed richards and those guys will
tell you you're a one-shot for success
and they'll put all that weight and all
that pressure on your shoulders and say
only you can really bring it into all
this but the reality is there is no
wrong here there's just what's right for
you and if what's right for you is to
just
roll over and just let those hits wash
right over you then do that but if what
works for you
is getting out there and fighting the
good fight and taking all your rage and
all your anger out on destroying this
villain then do that too
and that's exactly what what dylan does
and this is an actual this is a
fantastic thing
to bring into the story because it
really gives a lot of context
to the the segment we saw in the last
video where dylan goes out there
and just starts blasting the symbiotes
off of all these different individuals
who have been captured by
by null because it's not necessarily you
know dylan doing this and then
falling down the dark side right it's
not like he's anakin skywalker right
succumbing to his evil
and falling down the dark side and
eventually he's gonna become a sith lord
it's not like that right it's him
basically saying like if the world is
going to feel my pain then at least i'll
do some good with it right and i'll take
out this villain and i'll save all these
different heroes who are out there now
while that's going on
switching over to eddie brock there's an
interesting kind of connection here
and the reason why is because as null is
losing these individuals who have been
bonded to it right captain america and
the various x-men who were there and so
on and so forth that eddie brock
actually feels it notice that flash
thompson agent venom and rex strickland
do not experience this in the same way
and this is really kind of donnicate
saying like there is a unique connection
between eddie brock and noel the
symbiote god right there's a unique
connection between these two and it's
really kind of his way of saying like in
the end it's all gonna come down to
eddie but one of the things
is when he's asked like what's going on
here eddie's response is
like null is being hurt like like
somebody out there is hurting null now
you also get this funny moment right i
mean what would what would a venom
coming be without agent venom having
some kind of comedic element
and so it's one of these things where
where eddie brock believed that like
flash thompson was just gone forever
that when he was when
he was effectively killed off that he
was gone that he was never gonna come
back
and so where flash says hey man like
understand that when you absorb my codex
i mean sure you absorbed that part of me
but my essence was still alive this
place this kind of hive
is essentially the afterlife for
individuals who are bonded to a symbiote
right it's effectively where they go
when they die or at least that seems to
be the case and in fact donnie case is
actually going to expand on this here in
a minute but it's kind of like this way
station right it's where they go when
they end up passing on and so flash
thompson was there when eddie brock went
to flash's grave and eddie asked them
that he's like were you there like were
you able to see me when i when i went to
your grave and he's like yeah man when
you were talking about how like i was
the best venom ever and i was better
than you and i was the greatest hero
ever in the history of anybody who's
ever been venom
you know eddie's like well i mean you
know i wouldn't i wouldn't get all
carried away and he's like yeah man i
heard all that man
i heard how i was just a much better
venom than you are but it's a little bit
of humor here right a little bit of
comedy kind of going back and that's one
of the things that's so great about this
is i would love to see like a legitimate
actual team up
you know like a team-up comic between
like eddie brock is venom and flash
thompson as agent venom right like i
mean like an actual
ongoing series like a buddy cops series
i would love to see that but i think it
would be absolutely amazing though you
know with that that kind of a story let
me know if you guys would want to see
something like that because i feel like
that would be legit right i feel like
that would be that'd be absolutely
awesome uh i'm actually gonna post that
question in the community section of the
youtube channel those of you guys who
don't know
i've taken to the community section more
frequently which is basically a way for
me to like talk to you guys directly to
do polls different things like that
and so i think i'm gonna ask that
question in the community section on my
youtube channel
like should we get an agent venom flash
thompson and eddie brock venom team-up
book like a buddy cop book and i feel
like people are going to be like
yes we should definitely get that but
one of the things that they really begin
to pick up on
is that all these individuals who have
basically been ensnared by
uh null who have kind of been held in
this particular place are effectively
being freed that dylan is freeing them
from knowles capture right from nols
control
and they're just kind of getting back
out there into the world one of the
other things that begins to happen
is there's this giant red rift that
basically opens up and initially they're
a little skeptical they don't really
know
exactly what this thing is but that's
when they begin to realize that this
place that they're in
is not really the afterlife for people
who have been infected with the venom
symbiote or bonded to the venom symbiote
instead it's essentially a way station
you know that they're kind of trapped
here by null so under normal
circumstances what would happen
is like you know flash thompson for
example when he was essentially killed
that he would just
go on to the afterlife but because null
controls all these symbiotes to be
bonded with a symbiote means to come
under the influence of null but null's
influence is weakening right this kind
of place where he's keeping them trapped
in is weakening and so this portal
opening up is basically
their gateway to the afterlife the issue
that they have here is they're kind of
begging the question is it one of these
things where it leads them to like
heaven to the actual afterlife
or does it lead them to somewhere
somewhere worse right does it lead them
to like yet another stage of knoll's
captivity and what they end up realizing
once they pass through
is it leads them to another stage of
null's captivity it really leads them to
basically the center of it all right the
central nervous system
of where null operates from right that
is kind of like the god hive is what
they refer to it as right the place
whereby null
seems to have the most control kind of
knoll's base of operations so to speak
but they also start to realize a few
things that are going on here that when
you have these various symbiotes who
have been
released from the various superheroes
out there that because they bonded to
these superheroes and then they were
released by dylan it now means they're
free of null's control
and so what null's forces are doing is
capturing these symbiotes and then
presumably they're going to go back
under knoll's control but this is
basically a way for donny kates to say
that like null's ability to dominate
these symbiotes is not all encompassing
that a symbiote
can be freed from null's influence now
we already knew that to a degree just by
virtue of the different
stories and the kind of history that
donnie cage had given us about like the
venom symbiote that was bonded to eddie
but it's a whole other thing to see it
on such a grandiose level to know that
like the simeon that was bonded to eddie
is not the only one
anybody out there bonded to a symbiote
once they're freed that symbiote becomes
so it becomes autonomous it becomes
self-aware and it functions of its own
accord and so what they end up doing is
coming up with this kind of plan
where the idea is to effectively free
all these symbiotes that are that are
you know that are now self-aware that
are being held captive by null
and then use them to free themselves
from this place and then get back out
there
now initially eddie's the one that wants
to go and do it but the response of
flash is
no right when all this popped off and
essentially kind of referencing the
the beginning of donnie kate's run he's
like when you first met rex strickland
and rex strickland sent you on that
mission and so on and so forth it was
supposed to be me who was supposed to go
i never had the chance to fulfill that
mission because i was basically gone by
that point and so it's basically flash
stepping in and saying i'm gonna be the
one to pull this
off right this is my mission it was
always supposed to be mine i'm the one
who was supposed to free those symbiotes
i wasn't able to do it so i'm going to
free these instead
and so he basically dawns the full on
like you know agent anti-venom armor and
i gotta be honest with you guys he
looks legit i mean tell me this isn't
amazing right like
like the agent anti-venom armor with
like like flash thompson's design
because
the last time we saw anti-venom i'm
pretty sure it was eddie brock so like
we have i don't think we've really seen
like flash thompson as
agent ante venom oh which is amazing it
looks amazing it looks so cool
it's one of these things where eddie's
like okay like you know this is kind of
like the
the final request of flash thompson
before he passes on
to whatever his life is supposed to be
and i'm not gonna deny
a dying man's last request so he's like
okay fine if this is what you want to be
then go do your thing and it's kind of a
funny situation here because and you
know flash thompson tells eddie the one
thing that made him weaker than flash
thompson himself right
and what he basically says is you always
questioned yourself
you always questioned whether or not you
were an actual hero and that's one of
the reasons why people
loved agent venom so much is because you
kind of had that little beginning
segment where flash thompson questioned
himself and wasn't really sure whether
or not he was the best person for the
job but as time went on he really came
into his own that was the evolution of
his character the way that rick raminder
wrote him he was just coming into his
own and eventually becoming the hero
that that
fans just grew to love and that's when
he tells eddie you know tells eddie his
weaknesses
you question yourself all the time every
step of the way
you never allow yourself to just accept
the fact that you're a hero now sure
you've made mistakes but so have i
i literally spent my high school years
beating the hell out of peter parker
like i was a dick and then i went into
the military i lost my legs i learned to
be humble and then i accepted the fact
that just because
we start our life out on a certain path
does not mean we're predestined to
remain on that path we can change our
faith we can become something better
than what we are
and that's where eddie really begins to
accept the fact that yeah man
he is a hero right like sure he's made
mistakes yes he was the arch nemesis of
peter parker for a long long time
yes he tried to kill spider-man yes he's
killed people in the past but just
because he's done these terrible things
does not mean that he's destined to
always be a bad guy
that he is by all standards of
measurement a hero right he was willing
to sacrifice his life to save the world
and so because of that
that allows him to kind of evolve and
basically say okay fine
you be the soldier and i'll be the hero
and so the result of that is you have
you have agent agent venom right flash
thompson who just goes running in right
who just just goes flying into this
whole thing it's like the coolest thing
ever right it's like it's like age it's
like flash thompson agent venom on full
display
it's the coolest thing he goes running
in guns blaze and shooting up all these
symbiotes and then one of them manages
to knock the guns out of his hand and
he's like okay fine
then we'll do the hail mary like he
pulls a grenade throws it and then blows
up this kind of nervous system area
and then of course he's basically
ensnared by all these symbiotes and
where you would think that he was gonna
die because the response of rex
strickland is oh my god they're gonna
kill him the response of eddie's
no like they're not going to kill him
all these different symbiotes
bond directly to flash thompson and he
emerges as just this gigantic symbiote
dragon it's his new powers right the
next stage of flash thompson
and it even looks awesome he's like he's
like an asian anti-venom dragon
it's amazing like it's it looks legit
and stuff like this is why the
storytelling of donnie kate's in venom
is so
landmark and so incredible because he
broke the the symbiotes out
of of noel's control he downloaded all
the codexes
into himself and now he's up there
fighting right now this is a very
important thing because what this looks
like donnie case is hitting at is flash
thompson's going to come back that he's
not going to stay dead right he's going
to re-emerge
and come back out into the real world
whether that's true or not i don't
really know and we'll just kind of have
to wait until the end of king and black
to find out because it may be that he
just legitimately dies right he just
passes on to the afterlife and the story
of flash thompson is agent venom is
officially over right we'll just
never see him again until some other
rider decides to just bring him back for
some reason but while all that's going
on you end up having eddie brock who who
is kind of talking to rex strickland and
saying okay like
this is our chance right we don't have a
whole lot of time before noel figures
out what's going on here but like we'll
bond to these symbiotes that are rescued
and we'll get the heck out of this place
only for eddie to turn around and
realize rex strickland has totally been
taken over by nola's symbiote god
knowles returned he's he's aware of what
it is that flash thompson and eddie are
doing and he gets flat he gets eddie
brock in his clutches with every
intention of killing him
in this final place but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
court if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]